Well,
uh,
just,
completed by Basic Law studies from the
Faculty of Law of Delhi University.
And then I,
I was working at the National Human
Rights Commission in India for a year
after which I got the Rhodes scholarship
to go to Oxford.
I did my masters in law at the
University College Oxford after which I
got,
I got admission to the Harvard law
school where I completed my llm.
And I briefly worked at a New York law
firm for a year after which I decided to
move into academy.
I was a visiting fellow at Nyu law
school after that.
And then I did some teaching and
research in Japan,
uh,
after we turn around in from middle of
2002 onwards.
I have been in Hong Kong for the last
over five years,
and that was,
that's my,
essentially in my academic background.